all right never happens that we see hazy
skies again right i wish that was the
case but boy you can see with the sun up
we've got kind of that milky haze back
in our air smoke advisory has been
reissued again for today with
unhealthful levels of smoke and ozone
especially for sensitive groups if you
have bronchitis or asthma it's just not
a good day to be outdoors temperatures
they look pretty good lots of 70s out
there
temps will heat up each day we've had a
little wind out at red rock and up at
kyle canyon but that's helping to really
bring in more smoke again and you see as
we roll the smoke forecast through
wednesday even into thursday early
morning hours a lot of that smoke wants
to hang around southern nevada skies and
of course the concentration of it is
still up north around reno hot hazy and
humid very uncomfortable across all
through the mid-south and they're trying
to
really just
recover from all that devastating
flooding in western tennessee
where so many people were swept away
from that flooding it's been terrible
there we've already got heat watches
down well south of us around the
colorado river valley close to mexico
the monsoon is still happening but it's
pushed way south
and east away from us we've just got a
hot last full week of august 103 today
southwest breezes will be up to around
25 maybe 30 miles an hour this afternoon
still hazy and hot tomorrow but even
hotter as we finish the week look at
that 107 friday 108 on sunday on
saturday next week our final days of the
month at least we see the numbers back
off a little bit down to 102.
bye-bye august it's been real all right
reel something